you know the nickname she gave her
father when she was growing up
she'd call me joey b so we may be
related or something
yep cardi b and joey b
cardi b gives joey b the third degree
yeah joey b like joe biden
the 27 year old rapper covers the
september issue of
l and in an accompanying feature cardi
also sits down with the 77 year old
presidential hopeful for a zoom chat
where she revealed her biggest concerns
ahead of the 2020 election i of course
want free medicare
and this is why it's important to have
free medicare because look
look what's happening right now you see
why we should have been having medicare
for a long time
i of course think that we need a free
college education
we're going to have if i get elected
president free college education
for four years of college flat out
anybody with a family less than 125
grand you're going to get a free
education
everybody gets free education for for
for a
community college cardi who previously
supported bernie sanders in the primary
election
is also focused on establishing racial
equality
i want black people to stop getting
killed and
no justice for it i'm tired of it i'm
tired of it
i just want more stricter laws that is
fair
to like citizens and you know it's fair
for cops too
cardi adds that the racial strife in the
u.s has even made some people feel like
they're not even part of america
like people we're not asking for
sympathy we're not asking for charity
we are just asking for equality we are
at
fairness and we are asking for justice
that is all we want to feel like
americans
the whop rapper who's also a mom to
two-year-old daughter culture
notes that prejudice is dangerous and
could be the start of a civil war
nobody wants to feel targeted nobody
wants animosity
we just want the best for us everybody
wants the best for
they self they future people racism
always have
have existed but i feel like right now
there's just
a lot of tension and we need somebody to
clean that
i'm just so tired of you oh and another
thing she's tired of
current u.s president donald trump oh
yes honey
i just want trump out you know what i'm
saying i just feel like
his mouth gets us in trouble so much
i don't want to be delighted i don't i
don't want
like you know we're dealing with a
pandemic right now right and i just want
answers i want to know when this is over
i need somebody to tell me
the truth the hardcore truth oh
snap snap the former vp assures cardi
that if he's elected
all of her concerns will be addressed by
his administration
but he says for all of it to happen the
younger generation has to
show up and vote on election day
in 2016 if 18 to 23 or
4 year olds have voted in the same
percentage
as the rest of the population we would
have had hillary clinton
not him the vote matters that's why you
keep talking to people about the need to
vote
the vote matters and while the younger
generation didn't amplify their voices
in 2016
joe notes that as a whole cardi's
generation makes him
so optimistic i'll make mistakes as
president but i'll admit to the mistakes
i make
and you're never gonna have to wonder
whether i'll keep my word
all right thank you i would like to see
you
just check me out i've never broken my
word anything i've said i was gonna do
never in my life